ברוכים השבים למחשוב קוונטי בפרקטיקה. הפרק הזה יתמקד בצעד הראשון ולעתים קרובות הכי
מאתגר בהגדרת תוכנית קוונטית. מיפוי בעיה כללית ל-circuit שיכול לרוץ על מחשב
קוונטי. הצעד הזה מתאר איך משתמש שמתחיל עם בעיה חישובית נתונה
יכול לתרגם אותה כך שמחשב קוונטי יוכל להבין.
בשיעורים קודמים בסדרה הזו, שיעורים שניים ושלוש, דיברנו על כך ששלב המיפוי הוא הצעד הראשון מתוך
ארבעה במסגרת Qiskit patterns. מהשיעורים האלה אולי אתם זוכרים שהמטרה שלנו הייתה לתרגם
או לשכתב בעיה חישובית לפונקציית עלות או לערך ציפייה
שאנחנו יכולים להעריך באמצעות מחשב קוונטי.
בשיעור שלוש דיברנו על דוגמה קונקרטית אחת עם max cut, בעיה
שהיא קשה חישובית ונפוצה מאוד באופטימיזציה קומבינטורית.
בדוגמה ההיא עברנו כמה צעדים כדי להפוך את הגרף ההתחלתי לבעיה קוונטית מקומית. אנחנו
הפכנו את הבעיה של מציאת מספר החתכים המקסימלי בגרף לפונקציית עלות. אחר כך שכתבנו את פונקציית העלות
כהמילטוניאן והכנו מצב קוונטי ניסיוני שמצב היסוד שלו
מתאים ל-max cut. לבסוף בנינו circuit קוונטי שמייצג את המצב הקוונטי הניסיוני
שמעניין אותנו ואז הוספנו את ה-gates הספציפיים כדי לאפשר למצב להתפתח לאורך זמן. רצף הצעדים הזה הוא מה שאנחנו
קוראים לו מיפוי. וברמה גבוהה, התהליך הוא כללי להרבה יישומים אחרים כמו כימיה קוונטית
וסימולציה קוונטית. עכשיו, אין מנוס מהעובדה שמיפוי יכול להיות קשה. אין
אסטרטגיה אחת שמתאימה לכל בעיה, אז זה יכול להיות מפחיד. היום אני אדגיש
כמה דוגמאות מייצגות של בעיות שונות ואתאר איך הן מופו בכל מקרה. אני אחזור בקצרה
על מה שלמדנו על בעיות גרפים כמו אלו ב-Max Cut ואת שאר ההרצאה אקדיש
לאיך למפות בעיות שמופיעות בטבע כמו בעיות מבנה מולקולרי בביולוגיה, בעיות מבנה
אלקטרוני בכימיה וסימולציה של תורות שדה קוונטיות בפיזיקת אנרגיות גבוהות.
אבל לפני שנבלה את רוב הזמן שלנו בפרק הזה בהסתכלות על דוגמאות מהספרות, אני רוצה לתת לכם
מבט ברמה גבוהה על הדברים העיקריים שאנחנו רוצים להשיג ולקחת בחשבון כשאנחנו ממפים בעיה. יש
כמה דברים לקחת בחשבון לכל סוג של בעיה חישובית שתצטרך להיות מתורגמת ל-circuit קוונטי.
ראשית, ייתכן שתצטרכו לפשט את הבעיה כדי שתהיה ישימה. זה משהו נפוץ ברוב הדיסציפלינות
המדעיות. זה לא ייחודי למחשוב קוונטי. אם שמעתם פעם את הביטוי נניח פרה
כדורית, זה רומז לעובדה שלעתים קרובות קשה לתאר מערכת בדיוק כפי שהיא נראית. אבל
במקום זאת, אנחנו יכולים לעשות פישוטים סבירים שעדיין יכולים להוביל לפתרונות מועילים.
כמה דוגמאות לאיך אפשר לעשות את זה במחשוב קוונטי הן להגביל את הגודל או את עומק ה-circuit על ידי בחירת
אנזצים יעילים לחומרה או קיצוץ אבולוציות זמן מורכבות או הזנחת
איברי המילטוניאן שתורמים מעט לאנרגיה הסופית של מצב קוונטי.
הנקודה הבאה שאני רוצה להעלות היא שתצטרכו לחשוב על כתיבת הבעיה בצורה שמחשב קוונטי יוכל להבין אותה.
לעתים קרובות זה כולל שאילת שלוש השאלות האלה. אחת, מה ה-qubits שלנו
ייצגו במודל הזה? שתיים, האם הבעיה שלנו רציפה? מכיוון שמחשבים קוונטיים הם דיגיטליים, תצטרכו
למצוא דרך לדסקרט את הבעיה. ושלוש, לבסוף, האם הטופולוגיה של הבעיה מתאימה לטופולוגיה של
החומרה? אם כן, מעולה. אבל אם לא, ייתכן שנצטרך ליישם כמה טריקים כדי שזה יעבוד. אז בואו נתייחס
לשאלה הראשונה הזו. מה שאני חושב שנמצא בלב כל הקשיים בהבנת מיפוי במיוחד כ
מושג חדש. מה qubit יכול לייצג?
Qubits יכולים לשמש לייצוג הרבה דברים. הראשון והפשוט ביותר לדעתי הוא צומת בגרף. גרפים
משמשים להראות קישוריות בהרבה סוגים שונים של בעיות מתמטיות. והצמתים הם אלמנט בסיסי שמייצג נקודה
או ישות בתוך רשת. תלוי במה שהרשת כולה מייצגת, זה יכול להיות עיר, אדם או
פרומגנט בסריג. Qubits יכולים גם לשמש לייצוג בוזונים ופרמיונים. אם כי אני אזהיר כאן
ש-qubit יחיד לא בדיוק שווה לבוזון אחד או פרמיון אחד. זה קצת
יותר מסובך מזה ואני אכנס לזה בקרוב, אבל באופן כללי שרשרת ספינים שעוקבת אחרי סטטיסטיקה מסוימת היא
משהו שאפשר לתרגם בקלות לארכיטקטורת qubit.
עכשיו, אנחנו מגיעים לדוגמאות שהן קצת יותר מסובכות. במודלים האלה, אין יותר טעם
לדבר במונחים של qubit יחיד.
במקום זאת, אנחנו צריכים קבוצות שלהם כדי ליצור משהו פיזי. לדוגמה,
קבוצת qubits שמוצגת כאן על טופולוגיית heavy hexagonal יכולה לשמש לייצוג מיקומים גיאומטריים של חומצות
אמינו או שרשראות פולימר. דוגמה נוספת היא סימולציה של פיזור הדרונים
במודלים של פיזיקת אנרגיות גבוהות שאפשר לעשות על ידי סימולציה של אבולוציית הזמן של חבילת גלים הדרונית. במקרה הזה,
רגיסטר של qubits יכול לשמש לקידוד מצבים שונים של שדה קוונטי. מצב הריק של השדה הזה או
חבילת גלים שמתקדמת על גבי הריק הזה.
עכשיו אני גם רוצה לציין שמיפוי הבעיה למחשב קוונטי כולל צעדים נפרדים שהם אחד מיפוי
המצבים ל-qubits ו-circuits ושניים מיפוי פונקציית העלות או ערך הציפייה
של האובזרבבלים והאופרטורים הקוונטיים. נראה איך אלה מטופלים בדוגמאות ספציפיות. אבל ב
נקודה הזו דיברנו מספיק בצורה מופשטת על האתגר שלפנינו.
בואו נסתכל על הדוגמאות האלה עכשיו בפירוט.
בואו נתחיל עם הדוגמה הראשונה שלנו. לדעתי, אחת מבעיות המיפוי הכי קלות היא זו שכבר
כיסינו לעומק, דוגמת ה-max cut. בבעיה ההיא המיפוי היה די קל בשבילנו כי qubit אחד
שווה צומת אחד בגרף שלנו. שימוש בצמתים על גרף הוא מאוד אינטואיטיבי וזה
מזל כי זה מתאים להרבה יישומים. הרבה פעמים כשאתם רוצים למדל משהו שמתאים ל
סדרה של צמתים מחוברים יחד, אם הקיבוצים הם בינאריים כמו אפס או אחד או כלול ולא כלול ב
קבוצה, אתם יכולים בפשטות ובטבעיות למפות את הצמתים האלה לביטים או qubits.
בדוגמה הזו, ואפילו בזו שהגדלנו ל-100 qubits בפרק 3, קישוריות הגרף
כבר תאמה את הטופולוגיה של החומרה העל-מוליכה שלנו. אז לא היינו צריכים לדאוג גם לזה. עכשיו זה לא תמיד המצב.
ואם יש לכם גרף יותר מסובך או מחובר מהדוגמאות שהדגשנו עד כה, תצטרכו
ליישם swap gates. אבל זה מטופל בעצם בצעד השני של Qiskit patterns שעוסק
בטרנספילציה. החלק האחר של בעיית ה-max cut שהופך אותה לכל כך נוחה הוא שאנחנו
כבר יודעים איך לבטא את פונקציית העלות כהמילטוניאן באמצעות הפורמולציה של QUBO.
זכרו שבמחשוב קוונטי ובאלגוריתמים קוונטיים וריאציוניים, פונקציית עלות המילטונית היא פונקציה
שמקודדת את הפתרון האופטימלי של הבעיה במצב היסוד של ההמילטוניאן.
כדי לבנות את המילטוניאן העלות, יכולנו להשתמש במחלקת SparsePauliOp ב-Qiskit כדי לציין את
הקישוריות של הגרף שלנו ושלב המיפוי לאופרטורים קוונטיים סיים. וה-circuit הקוונטי היה
פשוט אנזץ QAOA. עכשיו, אם זה לא מצלצל מוכר, בבקשה חזרו ותבדקו את פרק 3 שם אנחנו עוברים
על זה בהרבה יותר פירוט. עכשיו, בואו נעלה את רמת הקושי קצת. הבא, אנחנו הולכים להסתכל
על דוגמה שמודלה במאמר שנקרא אלגוריתם קוונטי חסכוני במשאבים לקיפול חלבונים שנכתב על ידי
IBM בשיתוף עם אוניברסיטת New South Wales. קצת רקע ביוכימי. חלבונים הם
מקרומולקולות שמורכבות משרשראות ארוכות של חומצות אמינו. השרשראות הארוכות האלה מתקפלות
למבנים מורכבים שמבצעים מגוון רחב של פונקציות ביולוגיות.
קביעת מבנה חלבון במרחב תלת-ממדי והבנת הקשרים בין
מבנה ותפקוד הם בין הבעיות המאתגרות ביותר בביוכימיה כיום.
חלבונים מתקפלים למבנים שימושיים בגלל אינטראקציות בין חומצות האמינו עצמן.
כשהמבנה מתפתל ומתקפל, חומצות אמינו שרחוקות אחת מהשנייה בשרשרת עלולות להגיע ממש אחת ליד
השנייה ועלולות להיות באינטראקציה חזקה. אנחנו צריכים לקבל המילטוניאן שמתאר את כל האינטראקציות האלה בין חומצות
אמינו אם אנחנו רוצים לחזות איזה מבנה סופי ימזער את האנרגיה. כאן נתמקד בשרשראות חומצות אמינו ו
איך אפשר למדל אותן על מחשב קוונטי ואז איך אפשר לקבל מרחקים בין חומצות אמינו לצורך
חישוב אנרגיות האינטראקציה.
עם זה, בעצם אספנו את כל התרומות הנדרשות להמילטוניאן כדי לסמלץ
אותו על מחשב קוונטי. בחלבונים אמיתיים, חומצות אמינו יכולות לתפוס רצף רציף של מיקומים אפשריים.
אולם, אנחנו הולכים להשתמש בפישוט כאן ולהגביל אותם למודל סריג שבו כל חומצה אמינית
תופסת נקודה על רשת. כאן, המחברים השתמשו בסריג טטרהדרלי.
הערה קצרה, כאן אנחנו מקודדים את הכיוון של הצלעות ולא את הצמתים עצמם כמו בבעיית ה-max cut.
כל qubit מייצג מסלול צעד-יחיד אפשרי לאורך הרשת הטטרהדרלית. שימו לב שהאתרים הסמוכים
סומנו בדיאגרמה הזו כ-A או B בגלל הכיוונים השונים שלהם בסריג.
שרשרת החלבון מיוצגת כסדרה של פניות או כיוונים על
הסריג הזה. כל פנייה בין חומצות האמינו יכולה להיות באחד מארבעה כיוונים
שמתאימים לצלעות הטטרהדרון.
ארבע הפניות האפשריות האלה מקודדות באמצעות ארבעה qubits.
זה נשמע קצת מסובך. אז בואו נסתכל על הדוגמה הזו קצת יותר לעומק.
בואו נמקם את חומצת האמינו הראשונה שלנו על הנקודה הזו בסריג הטטרהדרלי. הכיוון לחומצת
האמינו הראשונה לשנייה הוא שרירותי כי תמיד אפשר פשוט לסובב את המערכת כך שהצלע תצביע
לכל כיוון שנרצה. אז בואו נמקם את חומצת האמינו השנייה כאן. זה לא כל כך
קל לראות, אבל המסלול מהשנייה לשלישית הוא בעצם גם שרירותי. כל שלוש הבחירות היו
גורמות לשתי צלעות עם זווית של בערך 109.5 מעלות
ביניהן. בחירת הצלע השנייה הזו פשוט קובעת את האוריינטציה של החלבון שלנו במרחב. אז בלי לאבד
כלליות בכלל, אנחנו יכולים לבחור שהפניות הראשונות יהיו פשוט 0 0 1 ו-0 0 1
0. עם הפישוטים האלה, הקונפיגורציה של שרשרת חומצות האמינו ניתנת פשוט על ידי הביטוי הזה.
עד כה מיפינו את צלעות הטטרהדרון ל-qubits וה-circuit הקוונטי שלנו יהיה אנזץ. עכשיו אנחנו צריכים
לשקול איך לקודד את האנרגיה של הבעיה להמילטוניאן כך שמצב היסוד שלו ייתן לנו את דפוס
הקיפול האופטימלי. עכשיו לכל קונפיגורציה נתונה תהיה אנרגיה משויכת בגלל
האינטראקציות בין חומצות האמינו עצמן. האינטראקציות האלה חזקות ביותר כששתי חומצות האמינו
קרובות אחת לשנייה. ברור שחומצות אמינו שצמודות בשדרת השרשרת תמיד יהיו באינטראקציה
אחת עם השנייה. אבל בגלל שהחלבון יכול להתפתל ולהתקפל, זוגות אחרים של חומצות אמינו
גם יכולים להיות באינטראקציה. חומצות אמינו 10 ו-20, לדוגמה, עלולות להגיע לאתרים
סמוכים אחרי שהחלבון התקפל. חומצות אמינו שמגיעות להיות קרובות אחת לשנייה יש להן אינטראקציות
חזקות יותר ומניעות את תהליך הקיפול, אבל לא בהכרח יש להן אינדקסים שקרובים אחד
לשני. אז אנחנו צריכים נוסחה שמתארת את המרחק D בין חומצות אמינו I ו-
J באמצעות המידע המקודד על qubits הקונפיגורציה. ככה אנחנו יכולים
להשתמש במרחק ההפרדה שלהם כדי לקבוע כמה חזק הם באינטראקציה. זה קצת מסובך
אבל תישארו איתי כי זה טריק מגניב. קודם כל, בואו נציג פונקציה f sub a של i שמציינת האם
צלע a משמשת לפנייה בחומצת אמינו i או לא. כאן a יכול לקבל כל אחד
מארבעת הכיוונים האפשריים לאור קידוד הקונפיגורציה למעלה. אנחנו יכולים לכתוב את הפונקציות האלה ואז אנחנו
יכולים להגדיר הפרש במספר הפניות המסומנות a בסריגי A ו-B מ
אינדקס I לאינדקס J כ-delta N. למה נעשה את זה? ובכן, מסתבר ש
לסריג הטטרהדרלי יש תכונה מאוד שימושית. בואו נתמקד בחומצת האמינו הזו כאן. לא משנה איזו
היא, אבל בואו נקרא לה חומצת האמינו ה-E. אנחנו רוצים לדעת כמה רחוקה חומצת האמינו j תהיה. וכל מה שיש לנו
הן הצלעות שלאורכן השדרה צועדת. מתחילים מ-I שימו לב שצעד
החוצה מהמרכז לאורך סוג צלע מסוים נקרא לו a מאתר סריג A
הזה הוא בדיוק הפוך ומתבטל על ידי צעד החוצה לאורך צלע a מ
אתרי B. אז צעדים מרובים לאורך צלע A מכל אתר סריג A מרחיקים את
השדרה מחומצת האמינו ה-E וצעדים לאורך סוג צלע A מאתרי B
מחזירים אתכם. אז המרחק בין שתי חומצות אמינו I ו-J לאורך סוג
הצלע שנסמן A תלוי בהפרש בין צעדים שנעשו לאורך צלעות
A מאתרי A ואתרי B. מכיוון ש-A ו-B בהכרח מתחלפים ב
שדרת החלבון, זה נלכד על ידי האיבר מינוס 1 בחזקת K. והטיעון הזה חל גם על סוגי צלעות אחרים.
אז המרחק בין חומצות אמינו בצעדי סריג טטרהדרלי ניתן לחישוב בסוף על ידי
הביטוי הזה. אבל איך אנחנו מקבלים את ההמילטוניאן מהמשוואה הארוכה הזו למרחק הכולל בין חומצות האמינו? יש
בעצם התאמה של אחד לאחד בין המרחקים האלה בצעדי הסריג הטטרהדרלי למרחק
האוקלידי. ואתם יכולים לראות שכבר חישבתי חלק מהביטויים בשבילכם.
המרחקים האלה יכולים לשמש בחישוב האנרגיה של הקונפיגורציה שלכם.
בהתאם למטרה שלכם, אתם עשויים לקבוע מרחק סף שמתחתיו אתם מחשיבים את הזוג כמתקשר
או שתעשו משהו יותר מסובך. אולי זה לא ברור, אבל בעצם סיימנו עם שלב המיפוי
על ידי שעשינו את זה. המצבים של ה-qubits מציינים את הפנייה, ואוסף הפניות קובע את
המרחק בין כל זוג חומצות אמינו. זוגות של מינים שונים של חומצות
אמינו יש להם אינטראקציות שונות, חלק מושכות, חלק דוחות. אם אתם משתמשים בקונפיגורציה ובמרחק כדי
רק לקבוע אם אינטראקציות ידועות של חומצות אמינו דלוקות או כבויות,
העוצמות של אלה ידועות היטב. לא על ידי, אבל אתם יכולים לחפש אותן בטבלה כזו כמו הזו. אז לסיכום, ב
דוגמה הזו, ה-qubits משמשים לסמן מיקומים על סריג שיחד יוצרים שרשרת של חומצות אמינו.
ועל ידי סימולציה של איך הם מתכופפים ומתקפלים, אנחנו יכולים בתקווה למצוא תוצאות טובות יותר במחקר רפואי. עכשיו, אנחנו
דילגנו על איך לחשב כמה איברים של ההמילטוניאן הזה כי הם היו ספציפיים מאוד לבעיה הזו. בעוד שהגדרת
כיוונים על סריג יכולה ליישם באופן כללי יותר.
עכשיו ברגע שיש לכם המילטוניאן כללי, אתם תמיד תרצו לתרגם את זה לאופרטורי פאולי שהם
טבעיים למחשב הקוונטי. על זה נדבר הבא.
בואו נמשיך. עכשיו בואו נחקור איך לתרגם מערכת של חלקיקים תת-אטומיים לאופרטורי פאולי. חלקיקים
תת-אטומיים מחולקים לשתי קטגוריות. בוזונים ופרמיונים. בוזונים
כמו פוטונים או ההיגס מצייתים לסט מסוים של כללים סטטיסטיים ופרמיונים כמו אלקטרונים או נויטרינו מצייתים לאחרים.
ההבדל המרכזי ביניהם הוא שלבוזונים מותר לתפוס את אותו מצב. אין מגבלה לכמה
בוזונים יכולים להיות במצב היסוד או בכל מצב מעורר אחר. פרמיונים לעומת זאת אנוכיים. הם דורשים ש
לכל חלקיק יהיה מצב קוונטי משלו. לבוזונים יש גם ספינים שלמים בעוד שלפרמיונים יש ספינים חצי שלמים
כמו האלקטרון עם ספין חצי או חלקיקים אקזוטיים יותר עם ספין שלוש חצאים. כדי
לתאר מערכת של חלקיקים, אנחנו צריכים תיאור של האנרגיה שלהם. בואו נתמקד בפרמיונים. אנחנו יכולים להתחיל עם
ההמילטוניאן שכתוב במונחים של מה שאנחנו קוראים אופרטורי C. אלה בעצם אובייקטים מתמטיים ש
מתאימים ליצירה או השמדה של פרמיון ממצב במערכת.
אלה נכתבים לעתים קרובות כ-fi dagger ו-fi בסימון שאנחנו קוראים לו כימות
שני. עכשיו fi dagger הוא האופרטור שיוצר פרמיון במצב i. Fi הוא
האופרטור שמשמיד פרמיון במצב i. אבל זכרו שמחשבים קוונטיים בדרך כלל פועלים בבסיס qubit
עם כללים ספציפיים לייצוג מערכות פרמיוניות. הם לא עובדים באופן מובנה בשפה של
אופרטורים פרמיוניים. כדי לגשר על הפער הזה, אנחנו צריכים למפות את סימון הכימות השני לאופרטורי פאולי ש
מתאימים באופן טבעי ל-gates קוונטיים.
יש כמה טרנספורמציות כאלה לפרמיונים. בחירה נפוצה היא הטרנספורמציה של Jordan-Wigner.
מיפויי Bravyi-Kitaev ופריטי הם יותר עדכניים לקידודים פרמיוניים.
אופרציות בוזוניות לעומת זאת ניתנות לטרנספורמציה באמצעות הטרנספורמציה של Holstein-Primakoff או מיפוי ישיר
של מצבי פוק לתת-בסיס של המודים הבוזוניים הזמינים.
ויש אפשרויות נוספות לבוזונים גם כן. קידודים אחרים גם נחקרים באופן פעיל. אבל לעת עתה, אנחנו
הולכים להתמקד רק בטרנספורמציה של Jordan-Wigner.
אז למה אנחנו לא פשוט מקצים qubit אחד לייצג כל אלקטרון? ובכן, אנחנו לא יכולים.
Qubits הם ניתנים להבחנה ואלקטרונים לא. למשל, אנחנו יכולים בקלות לסמן ולזהות qubits בודדים על
כל מכשיר, אבל אי-ההבחנה של אלקטרונים אומרת שאנחנו לא יכולים לסמן אותם בכלל. אנחנו צריכים בעצם לסמן
במקום זאת את האופרטורים לפי אורביטלים תפוסים כמו 1s 2s ו-2p
במקום אלקטרונים ספציפיים. לכן אנחנו צריכים בעצם לסמן את האופרטורים לפי אורביטלים תפוסים כמו 1s
2s ו-2p במקום לסמן אלקטרונים ספציפיים. אז כל qubit ממלא
בערך את התפקיד של אורביטל במולקולה שהוא או תפוס או לא תפוס.
אבל איך שאנחנו עושים את זה הוא בעצם קצת יותר מסובך. אז עכשיו נציג משהו שנקרא מיפוי Jordan-Wigner כדי לעקוב אחרי
אנטי-סימטריה ולוודא שהסטטיסטיקה הנכונה של המערכת הפרמיונית הכוללת נשמרת. מיפוי
Jordan-Wigner הוא פשוט מבחינה רעיונית בגלל ההתאמה של אחד לאחד בין האורביטלים ל-qubits. יש
מיפויים אחרים שמשיגים מטרה דומה כולל מיפוי הפריטי.
חישוב הפריטי של מצב דורש התחשבות במספר qubits. במיפוי הפריטי ובחלק מהאחרים,
הפרשנות של qubit אחד מתאים לאורביטל אחד לא מתקיימת.
עכשיו בואו נעבור יחד על דוגמה די פשוטה כדי לוודא שאנחנו מבינים את הטרנספורמציה הזו.
נגיד שאנחנו רוצים לחשב את האינטראקציה של qubit יחיד f dagger f. מתחילים בהצבה של ההגדרות שלנו לאופרטורי
ההעלאה וההורדה. אז אנחנו יכולים לקבץ איברים ולהוציא מהסוגריים את מטריצת היחידה I ואת ה-1/4.
כפי שאנחנו רואים, נשארנו עם איברים שיהיו מוכרים למי שעוסקים ביחסי קומוטציה. האיבר הזה כאן
בסוגריים הוא לא אחר מאשר i כפול הקומוטטור של X נוט ו-Y. ואל
תשכחו את היחידה שהוצאנו.
עכשיו זכרו שאלה פשוט מטריצות פאולי. לכן הקומוטטור ידוע היטב. הקומוטטור של X ו-Y ב
סדר הזה הוא פשוט. זה 2iZ. תוודאו שאתם לא מאבדים את סימני המינוס ותקבלו את זה כתוצאה
הסופית. בסוף, הצלחנו לשכתב ביטוי פרמיוני ב
מונחים של אופרטורי פאולי שהמחשב הקוונטי שלנו יוכל להבין.
בואו נדון בקצרה באיך הינו מיישמים את מיפוי Jordan-Wigner ב-Qiskit כי למרות שאני חושב שזה
חשוב להבין איך המיפוי וטרנספורמציות דומות עובדים ולראות את זה מעובד לפחות פעם אחת, אתם
לא הייתם רוצים לעשות את כל העבודה הזו ידנית בכל פעם.
במיוחד עבור מערכות גדולות, אנחנו יכולים להשתמש בפונקציית SparsePauliOp ב-Qiskit כדי
ליצור בקלות את אופרציות הפאולי המתאימות ממיפוי. מימוש לא
אופטימלי ישתמש בלולאות מקוננות ולוקח בערך 20 שורות קוד.
אני אקשר את הקוד כאן כדי שתוכלו לחקור. אבל ברמה גבוהה, הצעדים הם כדלקמן.
אחד, להשתמש בפונקציית SparsePauliOps from list כדי ליצור אופרטור יחידה
שמתאים לגודל מרחב הפרמטרים שצריך למפות. שתיים, בהתאם להגדרת אופרטורי
היצירה וההשמדה שהוצגו קודם, להשתמש בפונקציית SparsePauliOps from list כדי להגדיר אופרטורי פאולי X, Y ו-Z.
זה ימפה את אופרטורי היצירה וההשמדה הפרמיוניים לאופרטורי ספין של qubit שמקודדים תפוסות פרמיונית
לבסיס החישובי של qubits ושלוש ליצור את ההמילטוניאן
הרצוי בבסיס פאולי על ידי הפעלת האופרטורים הנ"ל על האורביטלים הרלוונטיים. זה בדרך כלל מתאים ל
יצירת מטריצת יחידה שמייצגת את הליבה, האורביטלים הלא-מתקשרים, ואז הפעלת אופרטורי
היצירה וההשמדה על המרחב הפעיל עם משקלות שמתאימים לפרטים של הבעיה הספציפית. כפי ש
ציינתי, זה רק פירוט ברמה גבוהה. הקוד לא כל כך מסובך, ועכשיו אתם אמורים
להרגיש בטוחים בהתאמת זה לבעיות אחרות שמעניינות אתכם.
עכשיו שאנחנו מבינים לגמרי את סכמת מיפוי Jordan-Wigner, בואו נראה אותה בפעולה בהתקנה יותר מסובכת. אתם
אולי זוכרים את המאמר הזה מפרק קודם גם כן על דינמיקת הדרונים. אני לא אעבור שוב על המאמר לעומק, אבל בבקשה תבדקו
את הפרק הקודם אם פספסתם וזה מעניין אתכם. בדוגמה הזו, מיפוי Jordan-Wigner משמש כדי
לבטא את ההמילטוניאן של אתרי סריג עם L אתרים למודל Schwinger בהיעדר שדה חשמלי. כאן,
הרבה יותר קשה לזהות ספציפית מה qubit אחד מייצג במודל הזה כי רק
האוסף של qubits ביחד הוא מה שיוצר משהו פיזי. בהקשר הזה, חבילת גלים. במקום זאת, אתם יכולים בערך
לחשוב על ה-qubits כחתיכות מדוסקרטות של מרחב שבו כאן L הוא נפח הסריג שבו כל אלמנט או
תא יחידה כולל שני qubits. האופרטורים הפרמיוניים שראינו בשקף הקודם מתארים את האמפליטודה של
פונקציית הגל באתר מסוים.
אז ההמילטוניאן שלנו מכיל את אופרטורי ההעלאה וההורדה הפרמיוניים האלה. אבל כדי ליישם המילטוניאן
כזה על מחשב קוונטי, נצטרך לבטא אותו במונחים של אופרטורי ספין, לא האופרטורים הפרמיוניים.
אז אנחנו משתמשים בטרנספורמציה של Jordan-Wigner. אחרי הפעלת טרנספורמציית Jordan-Wigner, ההמילטוניאן
החדש שלנו הופך למשוואה הזו בתחתית השקף שבו sigma plus הוא אופרטור הפאולי X + iY ו-sigma
minus הוא X - iY. ברגע שיש לנו המילטוניאן כתוב בפורמט הזה,
החלק הקשה של שלב המיפוי מאחורינו ועכשיו אפשר בקלות לכתוב אותו ל-circuit באופרטורי פאולי.
לסיכום, דיברנו על ארבע דוגמאות של איך טכניקות מיפוי ספציפיות שימשו לאחרונה ב
תחום המחשוב הקוונטי. התחלנו מהפשוט ביותר והתקדמנו עד ליישום טרנספורמציית Jordan-Wigner על
דינמיקת הדרונים. אני מבין שזה הרבה. החומר הזה היה מאוד טכני
ואם לא ראיתם את זה קודם, זה יכול להיות מאוד מפחיד. החדשות הטובות הן שאני מבטיח שזה נהיה קל יותר ו
יותר מוכר ככל שאתם מקדישים יותר זמן לתרגול. וזה באמת שם המשחק ולמה קראתי לכל
הסדרה מחשוב קוונטי בפרקטיקה.
זה לא משהו שמישהו יכול פשוט לתפוס ולרוץ איתו מההתחלה. זה דורש קצת לימוד, קצת
גירוד ראש, וכנראה כמה רגעים מתסכלים. אבל אני מעודד את כולכם לשבת עם אי הנוחות ו
באמת לחקור את השאלות שעולות בזמן שאתם ממשיכים כי זו הדרך היחידה באמת ללמוד. תודה ש
צפיתם. זה היה פרק 5 של מחשוב קוונטי בפרקטיקה. בפעם הבאה אנחנו הולכים לחקור איך לסמלץ
המילטוניאן מאפס. נתראה בקרוב.